Mesdames et messieurs peuple des Internet bonsoir l'heure est grave aujourd'hui plus de 4 milliards
978 millions de propriétaires de chats se font maltraiter par eux
89.98 % de ces propriétaires laissent la majorité de la place de leurs lits aux chats et 126 % des lecteurs
du livre dont je vais vous parler ont repris le contrôle
Bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce treizième opus de ce calendrier de l'avent aujourd'hui je vous parle comme idée de cadeau du jour
un livre qui m'a beaucoup fait rire parce que j'ai un chat moi-même qui s'appelle Tamalo que vous avez déjà peut-être déjà vu sur mon
Instagram et si vous l'avez pas vu
c'est que vous êtes peut-être pas abonnés à mon Instagram vous avez le lien dans la description et
voilà c'est Fabien Olicard comme ça vient d'être marqué juste ici
et les livres qui m'a fait rire c'est pourquoi les chats vont-ils conquérir le monde? Des témoignages accablants...
enfin la vérité bon on va pas se mentir j'ai souvent du mal avec les livres
d'humour où à chaque page il y a une vanne un peu mise en page etc
ça marche pas trop sur moi j'arrive pas lire en fait et celui-ci bizarrement il
se lit très bien mais je crois aussi que c'est parce qu'il y a beaucoup de concepts différents il y a des photos et vous avez compris le parti pris
de ce livre vous attendiez à trouver des chats mignons de de livre et bien non évidemment sinon j'aurais pris un autre livre. Morceau choisis,
le top 10 oui on est sur internet même dans les livres maintenant le top 10 de manière dont un chat peut vous tuer
donc je vous lis les gros titres vous lis pas après le petit texte rigole en dessous
petit 1 ils se posent sur votre tête pour vous tuer dans votre sommeil
petit 2 il vous griffe souvent
petit 3 il vous oblige à le suivre
petit 4 il fait tomber des objets petit 5 il vous fera choper une maladie dégueulasse petit 6 l'utilisent la force
jour après jour grâce à son cerveau surpuissant le chat est capable de vous irradiés il utilise la force la force la vraie force
Tintin tintin le pouce en l'air du mettra
petit 7 il se met dans vos jambes petit 8 il vous fait de gros câlins
pour vous étouffez petit 9 il vous pique votre nourriture petit 10 il vous fait tourner en bourrique
méthode efficace utilisée par tous les élèves de collèges consiste à faire tourner un humain en rond pour lui faire péter une durite
répétés sur toute une vie comme peut le faire un chat cette méthode d'assassinat est très efficace et surtout ne laisse aucune trace FAUX
sont partout
il y a des photos commentées il y a l'analyse spécifique et biologique du spécimen du chat au tout début il y a son
emploi du temps aussi qui est très chargé on peut voir qu à
13h28 le chat conspirent avec les chaînes les autres chats du quartier qu'à 18h56
il ya un quart d'heure de folie obligatoire sauter, miauler, courrir donc à 19h07 dormir un peu parce que c'était épuisant mais à
19h34 surveiller le déroulé du repas y participer activement
20h56 faire beaucoup de bruit pendant le film pour que l'humain ne puisse pas le suivre
22h24 déposer une souris sur l'oreiller afin qu'il ne dorme pas tout de suite
23h02 prendre toute la place dans le lit pour qu'ils n'osent pas bougé etc etc
des témoignages je vous en lire un parce que je crois que
vous avez coup mieux comprendre de quoi on parle
je sais pas si vous êtes prêts pour ça anthony 46 ans célibataire j'étais dans le gouffre
mon chat me menais en bateau il faisait de moi ce qu'il voulait je craquais à chaque fois mais j'étais un battant
mais dès que je rentrais chez moi c'était fini il avait trop de pouvoir sur moi
en vrai je l'invitais plus personne à la maison sinon je serais passer pour une victime
observez la nuit pendant mon sommeil parfois encore j'ai l'impression qu'il va surgir là derrière moi
et ce qui m'a fait le plus marrer mais je terminerais je pense à vidéo là dessus
c'est que à plusieurs chapitres sont repris des études scientifiques
réel qui ont été faites sur le comportement animalier sur les chiens sur les êtres humains et sur les chats
et ils s'en servent pour les retourner avec humour pour prouver scientifiquement
que les chats veulent notre peau et ça c'est extrêmement bien fait en termes de rhétorique et d'analyse et
créativité et voilà il y en a trois études scientifiques dedans j'ai trouvé ça très drôle
je voulais donc vous en parler j'ai bien aimé ce livre je vous mets le lien dans la description ça peut être un bon cadeau
de noël ce livre comme ça des objets présentés autre chose des places pour aller voir fabien olicard a l'Olympia le 22 septembre
n'y aura pas de chat mais par contre il y aura peut-être toi ou moi comme d'habitude vous pouvez laisser un like à cette vidéo c'est pas encore fait ou vous
abonnez si c'est pas fait non plus je vous dis à demain parce que c'est le principe d'un calendrier de l'avent
on va se retrouver tous les jours jusqu'au 24 décembre et
passer une bonne journée parce qu'il était tôt alors à demain matin 6h ciao
Mercis a la communauté YouTube    vérifier par Paul